so while mcdonald's fries might look and  taste pretty similar in the uk in the us  in the uk we only have three ingredients  which is oil salt and potatoes the  mcdonald's french fries in america have  way more ingredients these fries are  made from potatoes obviously canola oil  corn oil soybean oil natural beef flavor  and i should mention that a natural beef  flavor contains hydrolyzed wheat and  hydrolyzed milk as a starting ingredient  and of course i have no idea what that  means dextrose salts  acid pyrophosphate which is used to  maintain the color uh are they that much  of a different color than the ones in  the uk is it worth it